today the mat while showing perhaps the
most egregious example of cancel culture
yet woke publishing companies are now
rewriting the books of dead authors to
make the language conform with left-wing
sensibilities one of the most revered
children's authors in the nation uh I'm
not talking about myself is their latest
Target also Joe Biden continues to
demonstrate his America last approach by
visiting Ukraine while his own country
falls apart marjor telegrin provokes a
heated reaction after suggesting a
national divorce to fix our problems and
conservative media figures continue to
criticize me for my mean language I have
some Choice words for them today all
that and more on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
the U.S blew through 31.4 trillion
dollar the trillion dollar debt ceiling
in December and still the White House
refuses to reduce spending while our
national leadership has buried their
heads in the sand when it comes to
fiscal responsibility it's time to pull
yours out our economy is in trouble it's
time to start thinking about your
Investments and your future you need to
consider diversifying into gold with
Birch gold Birch gold is a leading
dealer of physical precious metals in
the U.S their Dynamic team of former
wealth managers financial advisors and
commodity Brokers can help you diversify
your portfolio into gold and silver
silver they'll even show you how to
convert your IRA or 401K into an IRA in
Precious Metals text Walsh to 989898 to
claim your free info kit on gold and
then talk to one of their precious metal
Specialists with your retirement at
stake you want to be confident in the
financial services companies that you
work with including whoever you choose
to purchase physical precious metals
from so you got to text Walsh to
989898 and protect your savings with
gold today
you may recall a couple of years ago
when the estate of Theodore Geisel who's
better known as Dr Seuss of course made
the decision to stop selling a number of
Seuss's books because the books featured
culturally insensitive words and themes
one of the books for example contained a
shocking reference to Eskimos and we're
not allowed to call Eskimos Eskimos
anymore for reasons that have never
fully been explained but it's too late
to explain these things to Dr Seuss
himself as he died 30 years ago all they
can do is posthumously label his work
bigoted and shove a chunk of his catalog
into the memory hole which is exactly
what they did now many people the
optimistic ones anyway thought that
maybe the whole Seuss Saga represented
cancel culture at its most absurd and at
the very least they figured it's the
most ludicrous example of censoring a
dead children's author that we'll ever
see can't get worse than that but they
forget in spite of my many reminders
that progressivism is Progressive like
cancer it grows and spreads and doesn't
stop can't stop until its host is dead
and so this past weekend another beloved
children's author who died a year before
Dr Seuss found himself in the woke
cult's crosshairs in this incident
actually makes the Seuss cancellation
look downright reasonable by comparison
so the guardian reports on the efforts
by Roald Dahl's publisher to actually
rewrite his books in order to bring them
into line with modern sensibilities
reading from the report it says rolled
dolls children's books are being
Rewritten to remove language deemed
offensive by the publisher Puffin Puffin
has hired sensitivity readers to rewrite
chunks of the author's text to make sure
the book's quote can continue to be
enjoyed by all today resulting in
extensive changes across doll's Works
hundreds of changes were made to the
original text and some passages not
written by doll have been added but the
Roald Dahl story company said quote It's
Not Unusual to review the language
during a new print run and any changes
were small and carefully considered
now if you thought that the uh you know
Dei Consultants were useless parasites
what can we say about professional
sensitivity readers I suppose we would
say much the same about them but perhaps
maybe we we might give them we might be
tempted to give them a little bit of
credit for finding such a profitable uh
yet low effort grift and speaking of low
effort here are some of the changes that
were made at their best
quote edits have been made to
descriptions of characters physical
appearances the word fat has been cut
from every new edition of relevant books
while the word ugly has also been called
The Daily Telegraph reported Augustus
Gloop in Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory is now described as enormous in
the twits Mrs twit is no longer ugly and
beastly but just beastly
well that's good because now the line
has left open the possibility that Mrs
twit might be beastly yet not ugly
perhaps she is a big beastly beautiful
woman that might be a somewhat
incoherent image I can't imagine what a
beastly yet attractive person would look
like but at least you get the
alliteration there big beastly beautiful
reading more it says in the witches a
paragraph explaining that witches are
bald beneath their wigs ends with this
new line quote there are plenty of other
reasons why women might wear wigs and
there is certainly nothing wrong with
that
I'm surprised that they didn't add yet
another line to to note also that uh not
all witches are supernatural creatures
who create magical potions to turn
children into mice as they do in doll's
book you know there are other kinds of
witches as well in fact we even have
witches in Congress quite a few of them
one of them used to be Speaker of the
House it seems the sensitivity readers
missed an opportunity to fully combat
the stigma against witches I'm a little
disappointed by that hopefully they'll
catch it on the next go-round back to
the guardian says in previous editions
of James and the Giant Peach the
centipede sings on Sponge was
terrifically fed and tremendously flabby
at that and on Spiker was thin as a wire
and dry as a bone-only dryer both verses
have been removed and in their places
are the Rhymes Aunt sponge was a nasty
old brute and deserved to be squashed by
the fruit and Aunt Spiker was much of
the same and deserves half of the blame
this is another important edit as we all
know it's deeply offensive to call a
woman fat we should instead be polite
and merely call them brutes who deserve
to be squished to death
but you know we shouldn't be surprised
that these changes make no sense at all
after all the woke police they still
haven't quite figured out what to do
with fatness because on the one hand of
course they want to stop you from
calling people fat because it's
intolerant but on the other hand they
preach about fat acceptance and declare
that fat is beautiful but if fat is
acceptable and beautiful
then why can't we call people fat
shouldn't we would we be complimenting
them in that case I mean one of the
greatest things you could say to someone
is hey you fat ass is he calling them
beautiful
so the sensitivity readers are a bit
confused on that point but one thing
they know for sure is that any reference
to biological sex is of course terribly
offensive now reading again it says
references to female characters have
disappeared Miss Trunchbull and Matilda
one say most formidable female is now a
most formidable woman gender-neutral
terms have been added in places where
Charlie and the chocolate factories
Oompa Loompas were small men they are
now small people the cloud men in James
the giant peach have become Cloud people
Puffin and the Roald Dahl story company
made the changes in conjunction with
inclusive Minds which its spokesperson
describes as quote a collective for
people who are passionate about
inclusion and accessibility in
children's literature Alexandra strick a
co-founder of inclusive Minds says that
they aim to ensure authentic
representation by working closely with
the book world and with those who have
lived experience of any facet of
diversity I noticed from the publisher
it sits at the bottom of the copyright
page of the latest editions of doll's
books and says quote
the wonderful words of Roald Dahl can
transport you to different worlds and
introduce you to the most marvelous
characters this book was written many
years ago and so we regularly review the
language to ensure that it continued
continued to be enjoyed by all today
now as I said at the beginning this is
all significantly worse than simply
Banning books or taking them off the
shelves it represents a rather startling
escalation by the woke Brigade
because if they had you know removed the
offensive quote-unquote doll books from
circulation that would be a ridiculous
and shameful move just like it was with
Dr Seuss but it would at least be honest
I mean more honest at any rate and it
would keep the author's work intact
but now they've they've taken the litter
Liberty to rewrite the books and change
the author's words without his consent
to make it more acceptable by their
standards
and you don't need to strain very hard
to see where this is going I mean it's
one thing to imagine a world where
Shakespeare has been entirely removed
from the classroom because he was a
white male who authored works that
contained problematic themes that
Prospect is disturbing enough if it
isn't already happening which it
probably is
but now imagine a world where kids are
taught Shakespeare except they're
reading things that Shakespeare never
actually wrote
I mean I would rather Shakespeare be
cast aside as a toxic white male than
retroactively edited to be turned into a
woke transgendered polysexual or
whatever they would do to it yet that's
where we're headed
now the problem with this approach is
not simply that it's politically correct
we have we have moved way past mere
political correctness at this point the
problem is that first of all it's a lie
so you may wish that an author had
written something a different way and
used different language gone this
direction instead of that but those
wishes are born from the fact that the
work is not your work it came from
someone else's mind
you wish he had written it a certain way
but he didn't write it that way
he wrote what he wrote no matter how you
feel about it
this is no different from rewriting the
history books to tell the story of what
of what you think should have happened
in history rather than telling what
actually did happen
and of course that's exactly what
they're going to do with the history
books if they aren't already
the left believes that it has the moral
authority to alter anything it wants to
alter
because it doesn't believe that anything
that conflicts with their worldview has
any right to exist in the first place
and that's really what this comes down
to
from their perspective Roald Dahl had no
right to to author those kinds of books
in the first place
because it conflicts with with them and
it makes them feel bad and so he had no
right to do that and so that gives them
the moral license to do whatever they
want if that means burning the books
Banning them they can do that if that
means rewriting it it means that
this is not only unethical and arrogant
in the extreme editing a dead writer's
word so they sound better to you
but it also deprives Children of the
full enrichment and edification that can
come from from reading the Vivid and
even maybe sometimes a little upsetting
If the child is an especially sensitive
type uh words of a great imaginative
writer
see we tend to worry that this kind of
censorship will help to indoctrinate
children into wokeness and we're right
to worry about that we should be worried
about it
but it's perhaps an even greater concern
that it will help to make our children
into Bland boring people
which of course is inevitable
consequence of making them woke
and if you want to make children Bland
and boring and bored
there is no better way to do it than to
reimagine Great children's literature so
that it sounds like something written by
A diversity consultant
that is just about the worst and most
disrespectful thing you can do to a
piece of literature and it's also a very
terrible thing to do to the child who is
reading it
now let's get to our five headlines
have you gone to the grocery store and
not been able to find something as
simple as eggs that's an experience
we're all happening having recently then
when you do find them they're almost
nine dollars per dozen there are
shortages and you should be concerned
shortages don't just happen during uh
crises like Global pandemics or natural
disasters they're happening every day
and more often you need to be prepared
for them when they happen a great way to
start preparing is with the Jace case
with Jace medical the Jace case is a
pack of five different courses of
antibiotics you can use to treat a whole
host of bacterial and assist all you got
to do is fill out a simple online form
your information will be reviewed by a
board certified physician and your
medication will be dispensed by a
licensed pharmacy at a fraction of the
regular cost being prepared not only
brings peace of mind but also helps you
save time and money in the long run it's
okay to feel anxious in certain
uncertain times like these but it's not
okay to be unprepared you got to go to
jacemedical.com enter code wall should
check out for a discount on your order
that's jacemedical.com promo code Welsh
yeah one more note about this I think it
was the author Matthew Crawford who
pointed out an important change in
children's cartoon shows in recent years
aside from all the explicit left-wing
indoctrination that we know about we
talk about all the time uh the other
major change is that this is the kind of
thing that if you watch kids shows today
it's like you you notice it but you
might not be able to put your finger on
it until somebody points it out so the
other major change is that a a kids
cartoon show
used to be vividly drawn and the plot
and most of the humor would come from
the characters experiencing frustration
with the physical world right that's
what that's what most of the plots
revolve around the coyote failing to
catch the Road Runner et cetera et
cetera it's like every single plot was
that it was a character trying to do
something and then he encounters the
physical world and maybe he can kind of
defy the laws of physics briefly like
the cartoon character that runs over the
cliff and uh it was running on thin air
and then notices that he's running on
thin air and then he falls right but but
that's only brief and then and then
eventually though the laws of of uh
physics re impose themselves again and
then that's where the plot and the
tension and the humor comes from and
there was even violence in these shows
you know it was cartoonish and it was
played for Laughs
um but still characters were shot or
blown up or they were they fell off
eclipse and all the rest of it and in
this funny and childlike Way kids were
introduced to a world that will not
fully Bend to your whims and that has
rules and laws that exist apart from
your desires uh a world that that where
you're going to encounter frustration
and failure and all of that but kids
cartoons today are again aside from the
blatant explicit left-wing propaganda
along with that
they're Bland they're sanitized uh they
all kind of look
the same and there's no frustration like
no the characters never are frustrated
especially for cartoon shows that are
meant for very young kids there's
certainly no pain there's definitely
nothing like violence
um Crawford gives the example of the the
modern Mickey Mouse Clubhouse cartoons
where
you know again it's just a sanitized
animation it just looks Bland and boring
but on top of that you know the house is
like magical and it solves all the
problems for the characters and so just
when you get to the point where you
think they're about to be frustrated by
something something magical happens and
it's okay
um and
that's what we're feeding to kids and I
think what they're doing with Roald Dahl
and rewriting these books is a similar
kind of thing
just changing the word so that there's
nothing that might be a little bit
upsetting or a little bit frustrating
yeah describing a character is ugly
might be if a kid is sensitive and might
well that's a little rude so we're gonna
take all of that out add disclaimers
well this this character is bald but
there are lots of other bald people by
the way
just making everything kind of soft and
Bland and boring and this is this is
this is all the content that's being fed
to kids all the time
all right
so Joe Biden went to Ukraine yesterday
this is supposed to be a very big deal
for some reason we were supposed to be
very impressed by that fox has the story
says President Biden's surprise Monday
trip to Ukraine was actually an
operation that began under the cover of
Darkness early Sunday morning and
included a plane ride on an Air Force
c-32 jet a motorcade on an empty polish
Highway and a long overnight train ride
into the war-torn country the small
two-person print press pool accompanying
Biden on the trip found out it was
happening just days before it had to
arrive at Andrews Air Force Base in
Maryland and the wee hours of the
morning before being forced to hand over
their phones before boarding the jet um
the plane was parked in the dark next to
a hangar away from the tarmac with the
shades drawn the plane stopped to refuel
uh okay why am I reading this who cares
I don't need the whole Saga this is not
he's not James Bond he got on a plane
basically and he went to Ukraine's what
happened
um and you know what this would be a lot
more
impressive and harrowing if like Sean
Penn hadn't already been there
and other celebrities
and if cable news pundits hadn't already
gone there dressed like GI Joes to
pretend to be fighting the Russians
every famous left of center person has
been to Ukraine at this point it is like
it's a it's a tourist attraction for
these people and Biden was among the
last to show up so I find it for that
reason a little bit less uh impressive
although it is it is interesting that
Biden showed up there and um he's on the
the tarmac and you can see they have a a
place they they marked down a place
where he's supposed to stand
for the photo op in the middle of a war
zone right it's a it's a very dangerous
but they took the time to put some tape
down so that Biden would know where to
stand for the photos and they do the
photo op and it's just at that moment
when he arrives for the photo op do you
hear the air raid sirens going off in
the background
and other journalists that uh I don't
know maybe they didn't know exactly what
they were saying but other journalists
on the scene reported that it's been a
long time since they've heard the air
raid sirens and it just so happens to go
off the moment Biden arrives and the
cameras are rolling wow
very convenient timing
to make all this
quite dramatic and it worked for the
media they are very impressed here's uh
CNN talking about it
as our resident historian here place
this in the context in the pantheon of
presidential visits to war zones
presidents have visited Iraq and
Afghanistan in recent years but those
were U.S Wars this is a Ukrainian war no
U.S military presence on the ground how
significant
it's extremely significant the United
States has wedded more to the Ukraine
than ever before I I go back to history
and think of Roosevelt and Churchill and
FDR had to sneak off in the dead of
night even had a body double at one
point to first meet Winston Churchill
off the coast of Newfoundland and then
of course he had all those World War II
meetings between Churchill uh it's worth
I mean mentioning tortoko Solinski has
been called The Churchill of Our
Generation and Biden going there today I
think it's going to be a moment for the
history books it's like when John F
Kennedy went to Berlin in 1961 and gave
a speech at the height of the Cold War
Ukraine is the New Berlin it's the rally
point for nato in the the Western allies
and and the I think Biden did something
really heroic
hmm
heroic well you know it's it's nothing
like either of those uh any of those
other historical
analogs that he mentioned because this
is a scuffle well for for a few reasons
but the first reason most important is
that this is a scuffle between Russia
and a frankly irrelevant country which
has no significance outside of that
region no matter how much they want to
convince us otherwise it just doesn't
and
um unless unless we continue to try to
make it uh relevant by intentionally
trying to escalate it into a World War
but there is no reason maybe I should
rephrase there's no reason
why they should have any relevance
outside of the region where it's
happening there is no actual reason why
it should matter to Americans which
corrupt government controls Ukraine
is it going to be Russia or is it going
to be Ukraine's current government
which of the governments controls the
territory of Ukraine there's no reason
why that should matter to any of us or
have any impact on any of us
but even so uh very courageous abiding
at least that's MSNBC here they are
talking about not only how courageous
Biden is but what a coward Trump was by
comparison
the president has some wind at his back
I'm not sure that it was all pre-planned
but it has certainly all been well
executed his back and forth with the
nuttiest of the Nutty Republicans of the
State of the Union pulling off this trip
and these images of Defenders of
democracy from two very different
Generations walking the shoulder to
shoulder in Kiev what do you make of
this moment in the Biden presidency
well it's very important because in the
back of everyone's mind there's always a
contrast there's always a comparison and
this kind of dovetails of what you
talked about earlier that when the
president runs for reelection it is not
a referendum on him it is a choice
and if you compare and contrast Donald
Trump Donald Trump was afraid to go to
Afghanistan
um and Afghanistan I was afraid to stay
upstairs during the black lives matter
protests exactly exactly I mean very
little courage and you know having flown
into war zones a number of times both
Iraq and Afghanistan as a member of the
Senate
um was there moments that it was weird
yes but there was always a sense that we
are surrounded by the United States
military you're enveloped by the United
States military
Air Force One
good Welsh and she also she had to throw
that in there she's also quite
courageous herself Biden is way more
courageous than Trump they say this very
much has the whiff of like uh my dad
could beat up your dad type of thing
that's basically what this is Meanwhile
we're supposed to believe
that there was like any chance at all
that Biden would be a battle casualty
that's what we're supposed to believe
that there was even the smallest chance
that they were putting the president
United States in the position where he
could be killed by Putin as if they'd
ever take that chance
then again as I say this
maybe they would I mean the Democrats
are desperate to find someone else for
2024 after all
not to start any fresh new conspiracy
theories but the point is that this was
um more pageantry uh meant to puff up
this Ukraine war with Biden visiting and
visiting by the way while uh a town in
Ohio is still dealing with being
poisoned after a train derailment I mean
we have massive problems we can't even
keep our trains on the rails and so
that's the kind of problems we have here
not to mention at our border and
everywhere else and Biden is going to
Ukraine instead uh here's what he
tweeted about it he said
one year later Kiev still stands Ukraine
stands democracy stands America and the
world stands with Ukraine
well no America doesn't
um DC does Washington DC stands with
Ukraine America doesn't because America
is comprised of people and the majority
of people don't care one way or another
about Ukraine and there's no reason why
they should
and still to this moment
the proponents of America's involvement
in the Ukraine war the people that want
us to continue sending billions of
dollars over there and weapons and the
people that are pushing for even more
involvement potentially boots on the
ground and all the rest of it still I
mean these people I've had now
a year
to come up with some kind of cogent
argument
for why we should care about this and
they still can't do it this is the best
they can do what you just read in that
tweet
democracy stands
that that's it that's that is still the
entire argument now when this first
started happening you heard uh warnings
about how well uh no matter how you feel
about Ukraine America might have to get
involved here because Putin you know
he's not going to stop at Ukraine he's
going to try to invade all of Europe and
he's gonna you know we heard all this
kind of stuff and that hasn't happened
and it's it's not going to happen
that's just not a plausible scenario we
have to worry about about Putin trying
to take over the world
so that hasn't happened and instead that
means that they're stuck with this
they're stuck with a shilling for the
Ukraine war
um on the basis of freedom and democracy
never mind the fact that yet again the
Ukrainian government
is not a beacon of freedom and democracy
it's one of the most corrupt governments
in the world
and even if it was
you know there are
many there are billions of people all
throughout the world whose freedoms are
being infringed upon
and to include people that live in this
country by the way
um I mean after what we just went
through with with the covet lockdowns
and everything we know how how uh
precarious our own freedoms are
but you know versions of that happening
all over the world and
um people that are in really difficult
spots all of them there there are Wars
and uh and conflicts and larger Powers
trying to impose themselves onto weaker
powers and weaker people that's
happening all over the globe
and so why is this specifically the one
area that we have to be interested why
should this matter to us more than
what's happening anywhere else
they can't explain it all they have even
now after all this time all they have
are bumper sticker slogans about
standing for freedom and democracy and
that's the kind of thing that that might
have been compelling to a lot of
Americans I don't know 20 years ago
but it hasn't been for the past two
decades
because we've seen quite enough
of American money being spent more
importantly American lives being lost in
pursuit of Defending quote-unquote
freedom of other people
in other parts of the world
who very often as it turns out aren't
even interested in our idea of freedom
uh closer to home this is from the
Washington Examiner
reports uh it's President's Day and
representative Marjorie Taylor greens
got a plan instead of celebrating the
birthdays of America's founding fathers
George Washington Abraham Lincoln the
Georgia
America's founding fathers George
Washington and Abraham Lincoln
that's the way the Washington That's the
Way Washington examiner frames It Anyway
the Georgia GOP Firebrand is calling for
a national divorce tweeting that red and
blue States need to separate and go
their own ways she's also advocating
shrinking the federal government we need
a national divorce green tweeted from
the sick and disgusting woke culture
issues shoved down our throats the
Democrats traitorous America last
politics we are done and uh so that's
that's she tweeted about the the
national divorce and obviously there's
the expected freak out over this and
what's even more expected is that the
freakout deprives us of any chance to
have an interesting conversation about
it at least on a national level
um and what I'll say about it and it is
it is it's not it's not every day that a
member of the United States Congress uh
actually floats the idea of a national
divorce
I mean I'm not sure it was the last time
it happened you know after the Civil War
I'm sure it's happened before but it's
not it's it's an uncommon thing so that
is noticeable
um although she's not the only person to
talk about it and this is something this
is a it's a sentiment that I understand
I've expressed similar sentiments myself
many times going back years
you know and it's that's why I say it's
not it's something worth discussing
like if we were capable of being adults
and just having a conversation
it's not a crazy thing to talk about
because it is true that as I talk about
all the time our
The Divide
in this country and in our culture is
deeper and wider and more unbridgeable
than it's ever been in American history
and that includes a civil war I'm
talking about the ideological divide
when you have two sides and it's not as
simple as two sides because there are
factions on the different sides and
everything but just speaking generally
you have two sides that that do not
share anything like we have nothing in
common we have no
shared values whatsoever
and I've gone through this exercise
several times in the past of just asking
people like what do you what do you
think what what are the can you name one
shared value
that binds Americans together
one thing we can agree on
and I'm talking about fundamental basic
things
and there really is nothing
uh you you want to answer well we all
believe in Freedom
but that clearly is not the case
or at the very least we you know that
will uh raise the question of okay what
is freedom how do we understand that
term
and then you find out that for a lot of
people they say they value freedom but
for them Freedom means uh for example
mothers killing their children that's
the kind of Freedom they talk about
and it means children being uh being
liberated and freed from the clutches of
their parents by an overarching federal
government in a school system that uh
that that steps in between them and
severs the bond between parent and child
that's what they mean by freedom
so we don't have freedom in common we
don't have anything in common
and that is a serious problem and one we
should be talking about
what is it that binds America together
we are people but in what sense are we a
people
um
and it would seem like the only thing is
just the borders that we all happen to
live within the same borders but then of
course those borders are being erased so
we don't even have that anymore
so what's left
that's not crazy then talk about
National divorce but
the problem is uh is one of geography
it's just it's a simple logistical
problem that I think makes a plan like
this totally uh unfeasible it can't
happen
it's an issue of geography
yeah there is a there is a deep and
unavoidable unbridgeable ideological
divide but though that divide is not
reflected by the geography of the
country there are not clear geographical
dividing lines between the two sides
you know it's not we talk about red and
blue States but that is a massive
oversimplification
because even in the reddest of states
you have uh most the time the big cities
are going to be deep blue
and even in even in blue states you have
pockets of uh of of the state that are
that are red
so how exactly do you divide all this
who gets Texas for example I mean every
state you could do this
so there's just no way it just that
if you could divide things
geographically that easily
if we could say that uh well you know
we've got this deep ideological divide
and most of the people who are on the
right side of that divide live in these
states and most of the people that are
on the other side live in those States
if you could say that then I think it
becomes very practical we should really
be considering uh the national divorce
strategy but but that's not the case and
so I don't see how it how it works
foreign
like what's a better strategy I don't
know but that's why I said we should be
talking about it been talking about it
in a Frank and you know uncomfortable
way
nobody wants to think of their country
this way we don't want to think of our
country as as one that is like
where that we say the word United States
of America we don't want to think that
it's that we are united in name only
we might want we might not want to think
about it but it is the case
and we need to confront that
I wanted to play this club too Larry
Hogan is the former Maryland governor
and is gearing up for a presidential run
we think that's sure to earn him about
as much support as probably uh he'll get
as much support from the Republican base
as Michael Bloomberg got from the
Democrat base in 2020. it's gonna be
about on par with that which is to say
no support at all but here's Larry Hogan
um going after Ron DeSantis over the
weekend
my question to you is not whether this
is a legitimate issue to be talking
about it's about whether this is the
main issue or not do you view this as
the main issue for 2024 no I think it's
an important issue and I do hear it and
people are concerned about this as I
travel around the country because you
know the most people just don't think we
should be talking about you know things
like sex to young kids and then parents
want to be more involved in the
decisions about what their kids are
being taught however uh you know I think
some of this rhetoric is uh you know
something you know demanding that things
be done a certain way or that you can't
say this you can't say that we've got to
be really careful does it feel like
you're going the other way like it's
sort of like you're on one hand if
Governor DeSantis claiming hey I don't
want all of this but I'm going to tell
you exactly what you can say and I'm
going to say what you can't say well I'm
a small government you know Common Sense
conservative and to me it sounds like
big government and uh authoritarian uh
you have to agree with me and I'm going
to tell you what you can and can't do so
but it's an issue it's not the most
important issue I think more people are
concerned about the economy inflation
they're concerned about crime but
education is one of the things that
we've got to talk about
yeah this is this is uh I mean this is
you put them in the same camp as Nikki
Haley and these other Republicans that
are looking at jumping into the 2024
race
um it's it's they're going to run
campaigns that might have had a chance
in 2008 that's especially the case for
Nikki hilley Nikki Haley I don't know
we're not talking to Kelly that was
Larry Hogan but they don't exactly look
the same but Nikki Haley would have been
a formidable Republican nominee for the
presidency in 2008
um but it's not 2008 anymore and so
she's not anymore and Larry Hogan's in
the same kind of just kind of your milk
toast whatever moderate Republican thing
and uh and he doesn't even have the
courage to just say what he really
thinks and what he really thinks is that
he doesn't care at all about education
doesn't care at all about what kids are
taught he doesn't care at all about
about anything that has to do with the
culture uh any of the the so-called
social he just doesn't care about that
um
they also want to say that so instead he
says well it's an issue we should talk
to important issue it's not the most
important issue which situation there
are both sides to this and there are two
sides people care much more about the
economy
people do care about the economy
but they don't care more about the
economy than they care about their kids
and their kids education
like people wake up in the morning and
yeah they're worried about how they're
going to pay their bills but uh they're
also and primarily worried about their
children and the future that their
children are going to have and
um and so that is that is one of that's
like the most deep-seated
concern that an American has especially
a parent that a parent has
and this idea that it's
well not I'm not a big government
conservative I'm a small government
conservative
that's nonsense first of all that's the
other thing about these establishment
Republicans they all describe themselves
as a small government all they ever do
is expand the government that's all they
ever do
I mean we've had so many small
government conservatives that go into
the White House they're elected to
congress they they end up in Governor's
mansions and they don't do a single damn
thing to actually actively shrink the
size of government they just don't all
they do is expand it
and uh Larry Hogan's the same deal
the small government conservatisms is uh
it's just a it's another bumper sticker
slogan that he uses and it doesn't even
make any sense in this context
we're talking about public schools these
are government facilities
so let me see if I understand this
correctly
the person who runs the government in
the state you know the executive of the
of the state who's the governor
for him to exercise any control
over what's being done in the schools
which are government facilities that's
big government
they are government facilities
now if you want to argue that the
existence of the public school system to
begin with is a symptom of of uh of big
government
and we should get away from the public
school system entirely
and dismantle It Burn It To The Ground
and dance around its ashes if that's
what you want to argue then uh then now
you're singing my tune but that's not
what he's saying
he's saying that the small government so
so the public school system is great
government facilities where kids are are
brought and indoctrinated
but if anyone whether it's Ron DeSantis
or anybody else including private
citizens if anybody criticizes
um or scrutinizes
what's happening in those government
facilities then we become proponents of
big government
it's completely and totally incoherent
but what else can you expect from these
people
let's get now to the comment section
[Music]
all right
um so first of all to tell you that I
did learn a valuable lesson over the
weekend uh and the lesson that I learned
is to not let my kids throw axes at my
faces
um
and my my wife came home with this uh
it's actually a great toy it's a toy
velcro uh it's like a it's an ax
throwing toy but so the toys the axes
have Velcro on them and of course the
first thing I thought is that we need to
uh have someone stand in front of the
target so that the access can be thrown
like around their head looks like it's
like a danger act you know that you see
on America's Got Talent or something
like that and I thought that's what we
should do of course my kids volunteered
me as the first victim in this game and
here's the uh here's the brief replay on
that one let's watch that
okay
let's try not to hit me
you know I've watched that replay a few
times and this is starting to feel
flagrant and intentional I have to be
honest with you she put that ax right
between my eyes and some people have
asked me why did I think that that was a
good idea to do and the answer is I
never said it was a good idea it was
just an idea you know this is the
fundamental confusion that people have
about about me maybe about men in
general not that all men would make
themselves the target for an ax throwing
game I'm not accusing all men of that I
just mean that we don't need to think
that something is a good idea
in order to do it you know it we
couldn't know that it's a bad idea and
do it anyway
sometimes the fact that it's a bad idea
is what makes it appealing
and that's not that I'm totally
undiscerning when it comes to these
things in fact I I have matured a little
bit I feel like I have to I have to uh
reclaim my pride a bit
and tell you that for instance
two weekends ago I took uh my machete
out to help my son clear a path in uh in
the woods behind our house he's building
a fort he wanted me to help clear a path
to his fort and so I you know I look for
any excuse to use the machete because
it's a lot of fun and so I did and I
briefly I briefly briefly felt the urge
to try to impress my son by flipping the
machete in the air and catching it on
the handle and of course I'd make sure
he was nowhere near and I I briefly had
that urge but I didn't I didn't do it
I didn't and I didn't bring it up either
because I know if I brought it up then
he would try it
so the thought crossed my mind
and if this was 20 years ago and I had a
machete someone was dumb enough to give
me machete 20 years ago and I had that
thought I would have just done it and I
wouldn't have a hand today
but I didn't I said that's not a safe
thing to do
and now I just stick with uh I satisfy
my
urges for dangerous stunts by using
styrofoam axes so I have I think I have
them have grown I think is what I'm
trying to say
all right stacy says uh Matt we've all
seen way too many Sci-Fi movies also
Matt desperate for an alien invasion
well yeah it's exhibit a I don't I don't
deny that so what I would I criticize
people for watching too many Sci-Fi
movies and then you know imagining that
Siri or whatever some some AI chat bot
is going to take over the world that
they've seen too many Sci-Fi movies that
leads into that conclusion
I fully admit that I have watched way
too many Alien Invasion movies I mean
I've watched any movie that involves an
alien invasion or people encountering
aliens I've watched them all and I am
very much influenced by that and I don't
deny it at all
um doesn't mean I'm wrong though doesn't
mean I'm wrong
let's see Evan says I'm not worried that
AI is turning into a mediocre woman with
a liberal arts degree I'm worried that
Society is actually run by a bunch of
mediocre women with liberal arts degrees
well I think you're right and actually
picking up on that theme
um
this this it kind of brings me to my my
thought about this AI stuff and the
concern that uh well Ai and robots are
going to become human they're going to
become sentient and conscious and
self-aware and they're gonna take over
the world uh I'm less concerned about
that
than I am about
it going the other way see I think
that's what we have to worry about it's
not it's not humans it's not robots
turning into humans it's rather humans
turning into robots effectively I think
that's what's happening
we're already sort of seeing that with
people who you know they carry the
phones around they can't be without them
they're staring at the phones all the
words are totally dependent on the
screens and everything it's like
basically becoming these pre these
programmed robots you can't even drive
uh you know five minutes down the street
to Walgreens without using your GPS like
we are we are turning into we're
sacrificing
um much of what makes us human and
becoming robots ourselves so I think
that's
it's not as uh
you know it does it's not as cinematic
of a prospect but I think that's what's
actually happening
um
Thomas says there are moments when Matt
disses someone it's so true and so cold
that you feel it in your soul Chelsea
took a hit on that one
yeah she did but she started it remember
that she started it
and I do think this idea that like she
the other person is saying well they
started it the idea that that's uh not
a good excuse I mean sometimes it's not
but but sometimes it is like if someone
starts an altercation then uh they
started it I think it's perfectly valid
to point that out
and finally
Kitty Foods says someone got an F on
their science fair project because the
federal government shot it down
yeah that's uh in order for Joe Biden to
Salvage his own pride and his own ego
he's out there shooting down science
fair projects that people have worked
very hard on I find that really
offensive
you know it's no secret that the left
hates our country wants to rewrite
history and even our children's books as
we've already reviewed they villainize
Our Heroes and omit key details from the
historical record like the fact that on
Christmas night 1776 George Washington
only crossed the Delaware River in a
sneak attack against British forces
after shaving with a Jeremy's razors
that is a that is a historical fact few
people know that it's a sad reflection
of our great nation going woke but like
Washington before us you could fight
back against woke tyranny simply by
picking up a magnificent Jeremy's razor
during our 30 off President's Day Sale
it's time we celebrate history not
cancel it so unless you want our
founding fathers renamed to our founding
non-birthing parents go to
jeremy'sraisers.com today and get 30 off
any razor that's Jeremy's razors.com
today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
okay so it's been uh a week since my
brief but now Infamous segment on this
show about trans activist Dylan Mulvaney
the Tweet with that clip has been viewed
nearly 20 million times on Twitter alone
doesn't count all the other platforms
where it's been shared and reposted as
you know all I did in the segment was
speak honestly to Dylan and about Dylan
a man who degrades and appropriates
Womanhood while Shilling for child
mutilation and sterilization it does all
of it for profit real women have tried
to tell Dylan how demeaning his woman
face routine is but he only doubles down
on the mockery in response and most
recently he released a video bragging
about what an attractive woman he is and
warning women that he could steal their
husbands quote unquote this was a video
that provoked my response in which I
simply told him the plain and
unvarnished truth about himself that he
is not a woman that he doesn't look like
one but the whole degrading display is
not beautiful or remotely attractive
that he is imitating something he will
never truly be in other words I said out
loud what most people already think but
some of those people the ones who agree
with what I said and were already
thinking it we're nonetheless very upset
by my remarks and perhaps upset is an
understatement they've called me mean
and cruel and sadistic and this has been
going on for a week now with no sign of
letting up uh they've called me a bully
and a grifter
they've said that I'm only I'm only um
hurting the cause by being so
repulsively honest and remember these
are people on the right or at least not
openly on the left saying this
now I've already addressed the Critics
on the show but the criticism has only
gotten louder and more intense since
then and many conservatives in Media or
at least again people in media who did
not identify as leftists have joined in
the dog pile and what began as a three
or four minute commentary on Dylan
Mulvaney in the middle of an hour-long
podcast on Tuesday has now turned into
something of a demarcation kind of a
dividing line
it's been a very revealing moment
enlightening
um and uh and I think for that reason
it's worth revisiting one more time so
that I can make
or perhaps reiterate or emphasize a few
crucial points
in order to frame those points I'm going
to play a quick Montage of some
right-of-center media figures and
podcasters sharing their criticisms of
my Mulvaney comments and what you'll
hear in these clips doesn't come close
to representing the harshest rebukes
that have been directed at me but they
do capture the basic point that all my
critics have been trying to make in one
form or another with varying levels of
outrage listen
yeah it wasn't that good well
he was just being mean well I was gonna
say like what what he is saying is
actually genuinely like really mean
Parts yeah the whole thing is true like
it's not it's not like it's untrue it's
not like
Del Mulvaney is a male and he will
always be a male and no matter how much
makeup or face feminization or whatever
you'll always be a man this is like a
reality I have a lot of contempt for
these people like a lot of content
you're talking about like Woman face
people you're not talking about math
yeah right well I sometimes have
contempt from that but but less often
than I have content for Dylan Mulvaney I
have I I get where he's coming from
because like I have so much contempt for
these people and the more that this
drags on and the more that they
denigrate females the more that anybody
denigrates females the more angry I get
and the more contempt I have for people
who participate in that in whatever form
that comes in
um
I don't know how I don't know if there's
a necessity or a point in just being
like mean here's my take on it is uh
and I you know obviously I'm much softer
generally but like there's nothing he
said that isn't true but it accomplishes
nothing yeah all it does it's just so
mean that like
it won't resonate and it won't change
minds and I will absolutely say yeah
it's mean
yeah Matt Walsh is being mean I mean
come on Matt Walsh insults Dylan
Mulvaney as Eerie weird and bizarre you
can get the point across without saying
that the major divide on this video is
whether or not the language was a little
too harsh towards Dylan you guys know me
you watch my show you know how I talk
about these issues I am on the side of
this being uh too harsh and I know there
are many who will Who will disagree with
me but to me
there is no need for vitriol I mean
do you reckon he's into her
it so it does look like the sort of
thing somebody would say that when
they're slightly obsessed with somebody
yeah exactly look factually he's not
wrong yeah is he no
actually yeah
I I don't look if your job is to win
hearts and Minds
I don't think this is the best way of
doing it what if it's your job to get
clicks online again but do clicks lead
to changing of opinion no I I don't
think he's trying to change anyone's
opinion what do you think he's trying to
do then
uh
trying to make people on his side feel
like he's done something cool and said
something that they think I think
do you think that yeah yeah well you're
not trying to change Dylan
yeah I completely agree I completely
agree I just I just look at that and
just go
even people on his own side were like
hold on a bit mate
okay so that was uh Temple Jeremy from
the YouTube channel the quartering
Sydney Watson Amala ekpenobi from prayer
you prageru and the guys from the
podcast trigonometry now one thing I
want to be clear about here is that I'm
not mad at any of these people there are
no hard feelings we can disagree and all
that it's fine I could have done without
the snagness and the lame cheap shot
from the trigonometry guys at the end
especially in a video where they're
supposed to be lecturing me about the
value of taking the high road okay when
you're going to do that you can't start
the video by insulting me but we'll
leave that uh to the side for now
instead all I'd like to do is address
the overarching criticism one last time
first
you'll notice the connecting thread okay
they all agree that I'm right that what
I said is factually correct but I think
that it goes too far by saying it out
loud
Mulvaney's the one running around like
some cartoon of a woman passing out camp
pods in the women's room and meeting
with the president to defend the
mutilation of children but I went too
far
well see this is where we differ
because in the culture War
I don't think it's possible to go too
far by speaking truth the truth is the
truth it is what it is
it's the reality are we going to defend
it are we going to conceal it are we
going to embrace it are we going to hide
from it you can't have it both ways when
it comes to gender ideology the truth is
ugly it is brutal and harsh and
disgusting I wish it wasn't that way but
it is I didn't make it that way I didn't
create the ugliness
I'm merely pointing to it and saying
look at this look at it for what it is
but you would rather that I soften the
blow a little bit that I dress the truth
up to make it prettier more palatable
you want me to lie
to protect the feelings of our enemies
and make no mistake Dylan Mulvaney is
our enemy
he is an open visible active and
passionate advocate for the abuse of
children the war on fundamental truth
and the destruction of human society as
we know it
you wish to defeat this man in a manner
that will not make him feel bad about
himself but I'm here to tell you that
you are delusional
I'm not going to protect your feelings
any more than I'll protect his you are
deluding yourself
we got into this position in our culture
precisely by valuing politeness over
truth we got here by doing exactly as
you would have me continue doing
and what you blame me for not doing
we got here by refusing to speak the
plain truth and by allowing the
anti-truth Brigade to emotionally
blackmail us into silence they use their
own mental fragility as a cudgel to beat
us into submission
that's the threat right
and we let them get away with it
or you do anyway I won't
second
um
you say that I'm I'm not going to
convince the other side with this kind
of rhetoric
but here's what you have to understand
this is very important
convincing the other side is not my
primary objective
this is the core difference between you
and me
I'm not looking to reach an
understanding with these people
I'm not interested in compromise and
dialogue
for those who castrate children and
attack the very concept of Truth and
erode the foundations of human
civilization
my goal is to defeat and humiliate and
demoralize them
okay I want to destroy everything they
stand for
the other side is not interested in
compromise
they want nothing less than your
unconditional surrender
we have to meet them with that same
energy or we will lose or continue
losing
and by the way
this is also a good strategy because it
rallies people to our side it emboldens
the troops it lets people know that it's
okay to speak up and to speak truthfully
you know it's often said that um
that you shouldn't preach to the choir
that's basically what they're saying at
the the end of that clip there
just a pandering just pandering to his
own audience he's he's this is a message
that's meant for his own audience well
God forbid
God forbid I speak to my own audience on
my podcast
now preaching to the choir is a good
thing we need to do more of it
because if the choir is demoralized and
scared and cowering in silence then you
damn well better preach to them
what kind of congregation can you hope
to have when even the choir is too
afraid to sing in our choir those who
agree with us the many millions of them
have been cowed into submission they are
nervous they are timid like you
and then you come along and say that we
should ignore them and instead tailor
our message for a group that hates us
and will hate us no matter what we say
or do
this is not just morally wrong it's also
terrible strategy okay it is a dumb
strategy
in fact it's exactly what the churches
have done for decades
and it's why most of them are dying they
water down their preaching to appeal to
the crowd a crowd that isn't interested
in the message no matter how softly it's
peddled
and while at best because they did that
they they bore to death and it worse
actively alienate the very people who
are actually sitting in the pews
so that's what the churches do the
people sitting in the people who come to
hear it and then they give their
preaching which is designed to appeal to
people who are outside the building and
not even sitting there
the people they're outside the building
they don't come in to hear any more of
it instead the people that are actually
sitting there get up and leave
conservatism has made the same mistake
and at what point do we learn the
lessons that our own recent history
seeks to teach us
now
you say that we can't win hearts and
Minds by being nice
Because by the way I'm not saying
that we're only preaching to the choir
it's not that's not it we also do want
to convince people
but guess what
you don't convince people by being nice
you don't
at least not on a cultural level
I mean where did you get this idea where
did you arrive at this conclusion that
the way to win the culture is by being
nice is that how the left won the
culture
have you been paying attention at all
they have seized hold of our society
indoctrinating entire generations and
they didn't do it with niceness they
didn't win these flies with honey
they did it by being bold and aggressive
and by making their oppositions
arguments seem not only wrong
but utterly horrific and insane
that's how they did it
see it turns out that the tone of your
argument is often more important than
the substance of it and the tone that
actually wins the day on a cultural
level is the one that is unwavering and
which Paints the opposition as so
repulsive that you shouldn't even take
their position into consideration
now
the only difference is that they do that
to us dishonestly right they make the
truth seem insane
but what they're peddling actually is
insane
we have allowed them to make the truth
seem crazier than actual craziness
okay we take their ideas more seriously
than they take hours but their ideas are
insane lunacy
and we lend them more legitimacy than
they will lend to us when we are
speaking the truth and they are babbling
nonsense
you think this is a good strategy
what is the evidence that this strategy
works
we moderate our tone we seek to kill him
with kindness
while they recruit Legions by doing
exactly the opposite again I ask you
when will you learn
now finally
if you sense anger in the words that I
use when discussing this topic you're
right that is one crime I will confess
to I am angry
when I look at what these people have
done to our country the devastation they
have wrought on a generation of children
and adults alike
the bleakness and ugliness of their
worldview the moral and intellectual
chaos they leave in their wake yes I get
very angry
and when I consider that my own children
must inherit this culture that Dylan
mulvanians and his ilk will Prey Upon my
children and try to turn my own Sons and
Daughters into mutilated mutant
self-loathing Hollow Twisted shells just
like themselves
well my anger then turns into a more of
a boiling rage
and I know that I will do whatever is
necessary and I will speak whatever
truths are necessary
to protect my kids from this hellish God
forsaken Madness
now
I have personally heard from many
parents
more than I can count
who tell me versions of the same Horror
Story
a beautiful and innocent kid one day
seemingly out of nowhere gets sucked
into the gender occult and is devoured
by it
the child they held as a baby and raised
and gave their lives to and loved and
still loved
become suddenly unrecognizable
all of their innocence and light and
Beauty just drained out of them replaced
by this self-cannibalizing madness
for a parent to see this happen to a
child it is a fate worse than death I
would rather be dead than have that
happen to my kids
see the thing that I most despise about
Dylan Mulvaney is that he is part of a
movement which actively seeks to turn my
children into Dylan Mulvaney
that's why I'm entitled to my anger
and to whatever language I use to convey
it
I will say whatever I want to say and I
will be justified in saying it because
these people are after my kids
and yours
and everyone else's
and you're worried that I'm being a
little rude
well you see when it comes to my
children
the children that I cherish more than my
own life
if you think mean words go too far
then you would be very shocked to hear
how far I would really go to protect
them
trust me words are the least of it
so yes
my words reflect anger because I am
angry
but the problem is not that I'm angry
the problem is that you
aren't nearly angry enough
and that is why the be nice
conservatives are finally today canceled
I'll move over to the members block if
you're not a member yet become a member
and use code wall should check out for
two months free on all annual plans hope
to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]